hey guys
we are going to discuss something else
here other than the most verse in this
video
and that is the dinosaurs that have been
seen in the preview
of jurassic world 3 dominion while the
first two jurassic world movies and
netflix jurassic world camp cretaceous
introduced the concept of hybrid
dinosaurs
such as the indominus rex the indiraptor
and the scorpius rex which were the
antagonists of the first two jurassic
world movies and camp cretaceous
respectively there will be no hybrid
dinosaurs
in this third one instead the film will
focus on dinosaur species that actually
existed
millions of years ago dominion will
feature all new ancient dinos including
a couple that were recently unearthed by
real world paleontologists
so if you're ready let's get down with
the sickness
the preview takes place in both the past
and the present beginning 65 million
years ago during the cretaceous period
with composer michael giattino providing
the music the score
the trailer seems to be like a nature
documentary with us following a group of
dinosaurs as they roam the area
it is serene and tranquil allowing us to
appreciate our planet's natural beauty
before humans arrive
so what we get here are the
dreadnoughtus the queso cordless
the oviraptor the nasoceratops the
iguanodon
morris intrepidus and the giganotosaurus
which are seven new dinosaur species
created by the team
at industrial light and magic that have
never been seen before in any previous
jurassic films
and so these dinosaurs in detail are as
follows
the dread notice which is a massive new
sauropod similar to the brachiosaurus
and the bones of this dinosaur were only
discovered in real life
in 2005. then we have the quetzalcoatlus
which has an even bigger and scarier
winged pterosaur
way bigger than pteranodons they are
like tall giraffes
dragon dinos then the nasoceratops which
is similar to a triceratops and
or a cyanoceratops but it has shorter
horns
that protrude from behind its bony
armored plate forward
the feathered morris intrepidus is a
genus of tyrannosaurid
theropod that lived during the late
cretaceous period which is now utah in
the united states
this is the one that looked like a
raptor in the poster but is in fact a
relative of the t-rex
now we also see the iguanodon which were
large bulky herbivores with features
that include large tom spikes which were
possibly used
for defense against predators and
combined with long prehensile fifth
fingers
that were used to forage for food next
the oviraptor
which is a feather dinosaur that is very
similar to the velociraptor but smaller
in scale
and commonly known as the egg thief it
is one of the first dinosaurs with
feathers in the jurassic world franchise
which is more scientifically accurate
and lastly the giganotosaurus which was
one of the largest meat eating dinosaurs
it rome roamed modern-day argentina
during the late cretaceous period
it was even bigger than the t-rex but
smaller than spinosaurus
so in the preview we see a t-rex and a
giganotosaurus fighting in the middle of
the late cretaceous background
and the t-rex is killed after a very
short battle which was kind of shocking
as
even the spinosaurus and the indominus
rex took quite a while to get the
advantage
we then observe the dead t-rex and a
mosquito flying into the t-rex and take
blood from the area surrounding the body
of the t-rex
while also we get a close-up of the
t-rex's eye dilating
so the question is is this the same
amber mosquito
seen on john hammond's staff in the
original jurassic park film
well that is unknown however it is
evident that this is the origin story of
the t-rex we know
and love from jurassic world movies rexy
then in the next scenes we shift to 65
million years later
and now we're following the t-rex in the
present day
as it races through a forest pursued by
people in a helicopter
who are attempting to tranquilize it
with a tranquilizer dot obviously
and the t-rex enters a drive in parking
lot as the race through the forest
continues
causing mayhem as people try to flee the
gigantic dinosaur
of course it is rumored that the
giganotosaurus would be the main
antagonist in the third movie
and so this might lead to another
confrontation and battle
between the t-rex and the giganotosaurus
and then rexy would exact her revenge
and come to think about it they are the
exact ones that fought 65 million years
ago
well maybe clones of them but them
nonetheless
and so that's that what do you think the
movie will be released next year on june
10th
we will also dive in deeper into the
morris intrepidus and the giganotosaurus
in the next videos
so do like for support subscribe to be a
part of the mind cue family
and hit that bell button for regular
updates on new master videos
right here on minecu till the next one
take care fam